then I go back to your book how would a
patriot act let me ask you the simple
question this morning is the senator
from Kentucky Rand Paul is he a patriot
absolutely I mean at least in this case
he is he's defending one of the core
principles of the American Founding
which is that the government doesn't spy
on us unless they have reason to believe
that we've done something wrong and
that's exactly the opposite of what the
NSA mass surveillance program is about
we're working with a new technology in a
new time and space distant from 9-11
what would be your best outcome that
would appease Republicans furious at
their Senator Paul I'm adding that the
the key distinction is between mass
surveillance putting the entire
citizenry under a microscope of
surveillance versus targeted
surveillance which is about actually
finding out the people doing bad things
and monitoring only them and there's
definitely opportunities to pass a law
that says to the NSA you can and should
be spying on actual terrorists and leave
the rest of us alone and I think that's
the outcome not only Senator Paul but
all of his allies and both parties are
trying to accomplish Glenn is there any
level of oversight that would make you
comfortable with mass surveillance no
master valens inherently is wrong why
should the government at all be in the
business of collecting data about what
we as innocent law-abiding citizens do
and say and the people with whom we're
speaking it's inherently corrosive to
basic liberties that said you could
maybe can imagine an oversight framework
that would at least provide some
controls the problem is is that the
courts and the Congress have proven
themselves very subservient to what the
Pentagon in the intelligence community
wants they're very good at capturing all
of those institutions an oversight
becomes a rubber stamp so even in theory
if you could conceive of something in
practice in Washington and ends up not
working so even taking that criticism to
heart that the courts in Congress are
very bad it's sort of holding on to this
you said you could imagine a series of
controls that would provide oversight
what were those controls look like I
mean I think the core principle that we
subtle on as a nation in the 70s after
all of those spying abuses of the
changer Hoover years and the Nixon years
were revealed was this idea that in
order to trust the government in spying
on people they have to go to a court and
present evidence that the person on whom
they want to spy is actually guilty of
something or engaged in some kind of
wrongdoing and so if you had a robust
court where two sides were in attendance
so one side was arguing the case of the
against the government you have some
transparency to that court it operated
like a real judiciary and then the NSA
could only spy on the PA when they
convinced a real court that they
deserved it that would be the kind of
thing that could work Glenn we had a
guest on earlier on Bloomberg
surveillance a flat-out called Edward
Snowden a traitor that is a polarizing
language of this moment where do you
want this debate to be in two years if
we're that polarized right now in
America about our spying where can we
constructively be two years from now I'm
an think it's moved a lot in two years
you've had public figures like Juan
Williams and hot and Carter the former
assistant secretary of state come out in
the last couple months and say you know
what I was wrong about Edward Snowden
and it's the same trajectory is what
happened with Daniel Ellsberg people
called him a traitor and now he's widely
regarded as a hero but I think the
bigger and more important question is
surveillance not snowed in and on that
this is going to be the first time in
the post 9-11 era that we take away
powers from the government in the name
of terrorism rather than give them more
powers and I think that's critical very
quickly here Glenn from where you sit
can rand paul uses as a constructive
political exercise with the events of
the last 24 hours benefit his campaign
yeah he's galvanizing the critical
debate and as I always understood that
the presidential politics are supposed
to be about plain green well thank you
so much greatly appreciated from real
nice one